[Music]
hello everybody welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is joshua fields milburn
and i'm ryan nicodemus and together we
are the minimalists we have made more
progress in recent years than any other
time in human history automobiles planes
smartphones antibiotics
comfortable shoes
the list of progress is endless
but have some of these so-called
advancements disconnected us from our
humanity have our achievements actually
caused us more suffering
i rarely make brazen claims but today
on the public podcast we're talking
about something that has personally
changed my life we're talking about
earthing we're talking about grounding
with our new friend clint ober he's the
author of this book it's called earthing
and the subtitle is the most important
discovery
ever
now hold this up if you're watching on
youtube
clint thank you for being here today
yeah thank you for having me i really
appreciate the opportunity to be here
and share it's awesome to be here and
yeah as your subtitle says it is the
most important health discovery it's
it's amazing i can't wait to dive into
it i thought that was hyperbole when i
first read it i was like oh no
what do you mean how could earthing
what is her thing yeah we're gonna talk
about that today we're gonna talk about
a lot also this thursday on the
minimalist private podcast ryan clint
and i we're gonna talk about harmful
emfs we're gonna talk about the damage
caused by disconnection we'll dive deep
into clint's personal story with
grounding and health issues and we're
gonna talk about alternative healing
practices that have helped people who
haven't found relief from traditional
medicine you can check that out at
patreon.com
the minimalist your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free because
advertisements suck
now clint let me just start here okay
man
few things
have changed my life like earthing has
one year ago
this month
i was looking for something to help with
some pain some autoimmune related pain i
tried a bunch of different things some
things helped a little bit sometimes it
was like putting a band-aid on a bullet
hole
and then i stumbled across grounding and
i stumbled across you and your work and
you made this great
film this movie about earthing
and i was like
this seems a little crazy but i gotta i
gotta check this out i wanna
start the episode by saying none of this
is medical advice consult your doctor
there's some information that we're
gonna be sharing with you today but uh
we're not giving you any advice here but
of course long-time listeners of the
podcast know ryan and i are not in the
advice business anyway let's start with
a question here a question from one of
our patreon supporters tanya has a
question for us what is the science
behind grounding and how can i explain
it to my husband who dislikes anything
he perceives as hippie woo-woo or
spiritual sounds like me
this is the number one question because
even i who have benefited so much from
earthing
i
have trouble explaining it in a way that
doesn't seem absolutely insane but
thankfully we have clint over here who
wrote this book with the medical doctor
and martin zucker and and so there's a
lot of science in the book but what is
the science behind grounding how do i
explain it to a layperson clint
well
i've
spent 23 years
trying to do that
and i'm still very challenged
but the thing i've learned over the
years is the only way
you can really explain
what grounding i can explain it
technically is very simple the earth has
a negative charge that's why we ground
everything electrical to the earth in
order to maintain electrical stability
the human body is the most electrical
thing in our environment
and it
and it used to be naturally grounded to
the earth before the 60s when we
invented
rubber sole shoes but everything in the
body needs
to i mean we need to be grounded and for
electrical stability and primarily our
immune system but it takes a little bit
to explain that and most people don't
want to learn the tech they don't want
to learn the science they just said if
this works um give me give me two i need
one for me and one for my mom
um but basically what i have learned is
i started out grounding people one at a
time
23 years ago
and then sometimes 100 at a time
sometimes 300 500 800
uh the longevity conferences with david
wolf we would ground up to 1500 people
at a time but by grounding people and
letting them experience it for a half
hour or an hour or three days during a
seminar uh it's life-changing and people
get up and say why didn't somebody tell
me about this
and it's really a challenge so it's
really the best way to understand
grounding is to look at the earthing
movie because there is a body of
evidence
that speaks to most
women
moms and caregivers and then go outdoors
take a chair put your take your shoes
off put your put the chair outdoors on
the grass put your feet on the grass or
just sit on the grass with your hands
and your feet and experience grounding
yeah if you have inflammation and
pain in your but if you have pain in
your body you have inflammation you
can't have pain without inflammation so
what grounding does is it reduces the
inflammation in your body there's a
whole science behind it there's 20
peer-reviewed published studies on it uh
you have the earthing movie there's a
plethora of material out there
but it's really as simple as going
outdoors and doing your own study
putting your bare feet on the earth
putting your hands on the earth and
notice the difference you'll go to the
beach for a few hours yeah and notice
how you feel after
i like after i go surfing like i mean
i'm tired but i always feel more relaxed
when i get out of the ocean for sure so
but but it's really it's it's all about
we used to be naturally grounded all
animals who live in nature they are
naturally grounded they don't suffer
cardiovascular disease lupus ms autism
and cancer and all of these modern
health disorders yet the animals who
live indoors with their owners they all
suffer the same
health disorders as their owners
meaning 50 of them die from cancer just
like their owners but cancer rarely
exist if at all in nature
so
is we've disconnected from this
energetic source that maintains the
electrical stability of the body and
primarily the immune system yeah so so
you could you know scientifically talk
about like the charge that the body
holds and how this basically creates a
perfect environment for inflammation to
to persist and how grounding can kind of
take out that uh that electric charge
but really what i hear you saying clint
is seeing is believing and that's how
most of us really are try it out for
ourselves actually see how it works you
got to do your own research yeah but
it's free yeah and it's enjoyable it's
fun yeah i totally and so when i first
heard about this i'm like okay let me
i'm i'm in so much pain at the time not
anymore thanks to clint and thanks to
earthing thanks to mother earth in
general he just helped connect me
reconnect me to the earth
and what i realized is oh
i'm 40 now
i've been disconnected even as i was
pictures of me as a baby learning to
walk with shoes on yeah
i have been so disconnected from the
earth and i didn't realize that i was an
electric electrical being i don't know a
whole lot about biology i don't know a
whole lot about electricity i don't know
a whole lot about earth and electrons
and negative charge versus positive
charge i know a lot now because i read
earthing and what earthing did for me is
it made it real not only are there real
life stories in your book of real life
people who have healed
it convinced me enough without trying to
convince me it convinced me of seeing
these other people it's at least worth
trying yeah and i remember the first day
that i went earthing it was free i had
no product no service no subscription no
money paid i simply took my shoes off
put them in the dirt and
not instantly but within an hour i
started to feel some relief yeah and
then i started grounding every night
eventually i went to a clinton and got
some uh i paid for all of it this is not
this is not a sponsored sort of thing
right here um
we've got a grounding mat for my bed
we're standing on grounding mats here in
our studio right now that connect us
back to the earth so you don't have to
have any products earthing is 100 free i
was in the ocean this weekend and how
wonderful is that free earthing but what
i noticed after a couple weeks after six
weeks
my whole life
had changed appreciably and what i
noticed is that grounding didn't heal me
it's almost as though it was removing
the things that were creating the
disease in my life can you talk a bit
about that
yeah it's like in nature and i spoke
about the animals in nature health is
your most natural state
unhealth doesn't exist in nature because
you're it's going to take you out
but but anyhow
what i've learned over the years 20
years i've been doing this for 23 years
mostly observational i'm an
observationist
and i grew up in nature so i kind of
relate everything to the natural world
and that's my more my guide but but
basically
all the research that we did really is
about
uh removing you know grounding people to
the earth who had autoimmune or
inflammation related health disorders
and so what we you know they would have
the flaring arthritic pain so we ground
them to the earth and the pain drains
away
and and their body returns to normal so
it's just cowboy logic i grew up on a
ranch cowboy riding chasing cows but
anyhow um
it's cowboy logic in the sense it's just
it's obvious
uh
and so
we've tried to put the science behind it
we have
millions and millions of dollars worth
of research and and that was for the
researchers for the fda for everybody to
understand to be able to here's a body
of evidence to help people understand
what it's about but the average person
it's about my life is so busy i don't
have time for any of this
if it works i tell me about what do i
have to do yeah and if it works on one
two of them but anyhow it's really it's
about removing
charge from the body
and putting the body back in its most
natural
electrical state which is neutral with
the earth
so that there and then if there is any
charge in the body the
free electrons from the earth will
instantly neutralize it and maintain the
internal
uh workings or the integrity of the
electrical functioning of everything
that goes on in the body and everything
in the body is electrical first chemical
second hmm
every cell everything that goes on in
the body
it's it's about electro
it's a it's it's electrical that's
that's amazing you know josh when you
first were telling me about grounding
yeah i thought it was woo-woo i thought
i was a little hippie i know i got long
hair but that doesn't mean i'm a hippie
so but i'm not adverse stuff i try to
hold space for these things but i really
expected you know uh it to be similar to
like the whole idea of like here uh use
this crystal to like heal something
but actually it makes me wonder yes
yes i know exactly where you're going
where am i going with it it makes me
wonder like some of these things that i
always thought were nonsense how much of
it is actually nonsense yeah yeah and
then specifically with the crystals i'm
wondering if there's something with the
crystals that take away if there's
certain crystals that take away like a
negative charge i don't i don't know but
it makes me think like maybe if there is
any type of substance to these crystal
claims maybe it has something to do with
the electricity in our body i don't know
do you know
we set that aside so we don't get too
woo for this because this is really
about reconnecting ourselves with the
earth and there is what i've learned
over the last year clint is there is
nothing that is
so radical about this in fact it's
aggressively simple what we've done
is radical by inadvertently accidentally
disconnecting ourselves from the earth
on the maximal episode this week you
talked about how you saw this group of
tourists and they were all wearing the
same white nike shoes and it that was
sort of your epiphany like oh wait a
minute maybe we've accidentally
disconnected
from the earth and that disconnection
has led to a whole lot of suffering
things like well you mentioned lupus but
even things like sleep apnea jet lag
lyme disease
um
nighttime frequent urination especially
for men that used to be something i
would wake up five times a night to pee
and now it's zero or one time
after grounding regularly so as we are
grounding this leads me into
cam's question from instagram
in fact let's let's start there and then
we'll uh we'll we'll keep on packing who
would benefit most from grounding what
are the most notable benefits
so i've experienced a lot of personal
benefits reduction in inflammation seems
to be the big one right because the
inflammation is what leads to everything
else yes
okay the most important thing
is if you have pain in your body you
have inflammation if you are grounded to
the earth
part grounded to the earth and stayed
there then it would resolve the
inflammation and you can't have
inflammation when you're grounded so
that's the
premise of grounding
inflammation is something new it's only
been around i mean the concept of
describing inflammation came around 204
so it's only been around 18 years that's
unbelievable yeah in high school they
weren't talking about inflammation no no
so i'm
did i am i getting the question totally
yeah so who would benefit most from from
earthing i mean anybody seems like
anyone but yeah anyone who has pain in
their body but most importantly women
because women are more sensitive uh to
the things in the environment maybe
because of children and whatever i'm not
sure but but they sense everything in
their environment and it uh
it affects their sympathetic nervous
system so
and the sympathetic effects fighter
flight in in very subtle ways and so
your body becomes filled with cortisol
which
dampens in
the parasympathetic and so on and and so
that creates anxiety irritability pain
and so on
so but everybody is affected equally i
think but women are the ones who are
you put us this way 90 of the visits to
a practitioner for female
18 90 of all
nutraceuticals or pharmaceuticals are
female
men don't do anything no pain no gain
until you have your first heart attack
you don't take any of this serious
yeah
right and so what we're doing right now
through a lot of our so-called solutions
we're actually creating more problems by
not addressing the root of our pain the
root of our illness the root of our dis
ease
and what grounding what reconnecting
with the earth does it helps us create
the electrical charge
neutral charge in our body so that we
have the opportunity to heal
yes yeah it's a
it's about restoring the body to normal
in nature i mean
throughout all time we were naturally
grounded to the earth
and our bodies were always had a
negative charge so we have an immune
system that evolved that operated with
reactive oxygen species which are
electrically charged molecules
never an issue not a problem as long as
you're grounded
you know because you have excess free
electrons to mop up and prevent any
collateral damage from
the free radicals
but when you lose your
electron charge
and your body's full of cortisol your ph
is off which is another major electrical
and your
uh
you know the radicals just start
damaging cell and so you end up with a
chain reaction of the immune system
trying to put out a fire that it itself
is creating because it doesn't know that
it's no longer grounded or doesn't have
the natural resources that it used to
have in nature
yeah
yeah let's check in with our live stream
thanks uh to our patrons who are joining
us live today do you have any questions
in alabama we have a question from anita
do you have any grounding tips for
people in electric wheelchairs i get
static electric shocks when i touch my
grounded appliances at home after i've
moved around in my wheelchair
right
yeah the the wheelchair would have
rubber tires like rubber shoes
you move around you have contact and
separation so she would be building a
huge electrical charge
um so there's a couple of simple ways to
do it
one is
to get a grounding mat or something
that's grounded a patcher
but very simply you can
i don't want to get too technical
but you can just take a piece of metal
tape and wrap it around you know the
tire not the whole tire just
somewhere
you know on the wheel of the wheelchair
and then as it touches the carpet it'll
kind of equalize and discharge about 95
percent of the static charge but the
main thing is grounding reduces and
prevents those
charges in the first place to have that
on your body while you're sitting and
moving whatever that's
perturbing
the sympathetic nervous system i mean
it's the stress there's an environmental
stressor so a mat might be good you know
i'm not sure
exactly how to touch but go touch of a
cold water pipe or the cold water faucet
or touch the
stainless steel sink or touch the stove
that has metal i mean there's many ways
to do this to dissipate this charge but
she doesn't want the spark
well the spark is um you have to go back
and figure out the cost what's causing
it you're building this charge on your
body you need to find a way to dissipate
it
along the way rather than let it build
up to the point that you have five six
thousand volts yeah which is what it
takes to create that spark and it could
be also there are plenty of other
opportunities to to ground
either so if you're stationary in a
wheelchair yes right or if you're even
just stationary at a desk yes like and
you're sitting there
you can have some sort of grounding mat
that plugs into the ground of the wall
and uh and you can eliminate that static
that way but also when you're sleeping
at night you're gonna be sleeping
somewhere usually in a bed you can use a
grounding mat there to to ground
yourself for you know we spend more time
in bed than just about anywhere else and
it's the one time where we can assure
that we are staying grounded right and
the main thing in bed you're sleeping on
a foam mattress all mattresses have foam
and then you have dissimilar fabrics
meaning polyester
mattress ticking
and then
hopefully you have cotton sheets because
they don't store the static
but if you have polyester in your sheets
and your blankets then there's going to
be a static so you're sleeping in static
and you need to get rid of that because
it's unnatural to have the body charged
with static electricity especially high
voltage and people are unaware of it
yeah they do have those things you throw
in the washer and dryer
you know oh yeah like the dryer sheets
is that the dryer sheets to help reduce
statically yeah
yeah
yeah it's like we it's there
uh and the only way we notice it is
through things like inflammation but we
can't connect it with the the buildup of
electricity yeah that's the only way
yeah clint you were talking about that
on the the maximal episode which we
already recorded but you were getting
into your story and you realized that as
you started
grounding some of the pain was gone and
that was just like a really nice
byproduct for you for me and for a lot
of people they're seeking out the end of
suffering the reduction of pain for you
it was like oh wow this is a amazing
benefit especially with the people you
started working with yeah i i started
out
thinking that it improved sleep because
i could measure things and see things
but most of all i i i went to sleep
easier and i slept better and longer
but a few days later i recognized
via the help of one of my friends
bringing it to my attention that most of
my chronic pain
had resolved i i didn't have
and to explain that i grew up on a ranch
uh as a cowboy and you know they're
crazy people they ride they ride stairs
just for the weekend to entertain
themselves
but i skied for
maybe 30 over 30 years i played tennis
i've had every injury you can think of
i've had surgeries i've had and and it
at 49.50 when i started to
54 when i started to understand all of
this my body was full of pain
i mean i lived in pain and i would go
outdoors sometimes and look up at the
sky and say god why did you make my body
with so much pain in it
and then i realized he didn't later
[Laughter]
but anyhow um
yeah so
the thing i learned most of all as a
byproduct that after i stopped grounded
for a few nights that my pain went away
and i didn't even know it went away
because you don't remember pain if you
can't remember pain when it goes away
it's just not possible
yeah
do you have any stories that really
stand out to you of people who have been
helped immediately and who've been
suffering for a long time
any any stories that really stand out
yes we were doing a study up in san
francisco area
and we had a half a dozen
people that we were doing
uh in fact it's in the book there's
pictures of it
thermal imaging so we could uh
set up a thermal camera and see the
inflammation in the body then ground the
bottom of the foot or whatever for 30 40
minutes and then you know
retake the thermal image or just take a
video of the thermal imaging so we could
see the color change
you know over the half hour so but this
one lady had been
had a knee injury and she had had it for
about 30 years and in a small limp
and 30 minutes after grounding her the
pain went away
and
several months after that that she
indicated that the pain never came back
wow so what happened was there was a
pocket of inflammation in the body that
was walled off that's how the body does
that to protect the rest of the body and
it was oxidizing and degenerating
the
tissue and so on
and then as soon as you got grounded put
the fire out
then the immune system could go
immediately clean it up but i've seen
people have dramatic
uh results in five minutes life-changing
results in five minutes i have seen
uh things that i can't really get into
sometimes because of the nature because
they're so
um
sensitive to certain people like
especially women
and
but it's
it's just remarkable it's
uh again
when people are in pain
you know
um and then all of a sudden they get out
of pain and a few days later oh i don't
know you know
it's amazing yeah i mean you do remember
the the suffering it's hard you can't
replicate it in your mind but you you
can remember your lowest points when you
were in excruciating pain and i can
certainly remember that but it feels so
distant to me
now since i've been grounding
consistently every day let's talk about
some of the best ways to go grounding
it's absolutely free to go grounding uh
for me i walk to the studio quite
frequently i walk through people's yards
it's about a 30-minute walk and i'll
just walk on some grass or even some
concrete it can be okay if it's
on the earth there and um especially if
it's like a slightly damp or your feet
are a little damp but can you talk about
some of the best places to go grounding
yeah sure
for 20 years i've been
trying to educate as many people as i
can about grounding the number one thing
i tell them i said don't run out and go
crazy about anything just go outdoors
take a chair
into your backyard or on your patio your
concrete patio
and take your shoes off and put your
bare feet on the earth and just sit
there for 30 minutes
and notice what happens in your body
you're going to have a reduction of pain
you're going to feel better your
demeanor is going to change your
your color is going to come back your
circulation is going to improve that
brings your color back but most of all
the pain and the anxiety irritability
and stress and the anger that's in your
body it all dissipates and disappears
you can't be mad if somebody if you're
sitting outdoors you know grounded to
the earth i mean all that goes away
um so but anyhow then the most the
simplest thing to do is to go outdoors
and experiment
and that's what everybody tells me after
they see the earthly movie the first
thing i do is go outdoors and see if
this is true
we'll put a link to the earthy movie in
the show notes by the way if you want to
check it out it's free to watch on
youtube and it's also thankfully
commercial free yeah it is commercial
free and then we have a little 15 minute
preview of it that
uh i don't know i think they called the
grounded but
um
down to earth is what it's called anyhow
that one was seen by 60 million people
and we never advertised it it was just
word of mouth
people wanted to share i share it with
people all the time i buy this book by
the case and hand it out to friends and
family yeah and this is like the third
or fourth copy of mine that i've owned
you see all the underlines in it but
i what happens is someone will say i'm
really in pain i'm like here you got to
check this out
you have to reconnect with the earth if
you want to end that suffering right
so the the next thing would be
to
um
you know go for a walk in the park
barefoot uh go to the beach
any of those nature things natural
things think echo therapy i want to get
back in nature
so anything that is a nature flare to it
is usually grounded i mean here you can
walk on the concrete it's perfectly
grounded because the humidity
there's moisture concrete holds moisture
the humidity and then of course the rain
and so on there's a high
conductivity level in concrete but
asphalt won't be because asphalt won't
be so things you can't do carpets
um
glass tile floors or baked tile floors
um the imitation woods or the plastics
all the flooring in our homes generally
is not conductive and that's what
happens that's why it creates that
static charge on our body
um but the best things to do are
just find a little space in nature
create your own little sandbox if you
have to where you can go and after work
sit and put your feet in the earth for
30 minutes and drain the pain drain
you're not really training about what's
happening electrons are coming from the
earth and they're putting out the fire
but it's the same concept
um so
catch a cold water faucet take out take
a bath you know especially if you have a
home
that was built before
you know all the plastic piping and
everything came along
your bathtub would be grounded because
of the piping and the cold water is
always grounded to the earth
yeah i don't really know you kind of
have to experiment
but the main thing is just touch earth
barefoot on the earth no matter where it
is no matter what it is whether it's
pretty earth grass or flowered earth or
dirt it's all the same it's electrical i
mean it conducts an electrical it's it's
you know it's equal around the it's
around the globe and electro and ground
travels i mean it's speed of light
you know so it's fast it's not something
you're going to eat a pill it's going to
take an effect this is instant like
flipping a switch
and the healing also has to do with the
dosage so to speak unlike a taking a
pill we're not covering something up but
if you're earthing every day for
multiple hours a day whether it's
on a pad at night or you're walking on
the beach every day or just through
yards if you're reconnecting with the
earth you're going to experience
more of those those benefits yeah yeah
earthing is cumulative
in nature like the animals you'd be
grounded 24 7 and you couldn't have any
of these modern degenerative health
disorders
they just don't exist yeah but in so
what i try to tell people is any amount
of grounding is good and more is better
but if you have pain in your body you
have to get grounded and stay grounded
until it goes away because your body's
on fire and it's creating
you know you know cellular tissue damage
and so on but the more you ground you
put the fire out for even just a short
period
and the inflammation will come back and
then you ground more but there is a
cumulative effect yes so over a period
of months then your body is going to be
healthier and the inflammation
isn't going to be so out of control
and you know there are environmental
stresses out there like dust or
pollution and
you know lots of craziness but you have
to it's about your immune system you
want to ground put the fire out so your
immune system can clean up that damage
and then go back to maintaining and
sustaining health we don't realize it
but all of these autoimmune conditions
that people have uh
crohn's disease
ulcerative colitis rheumatoid arthritis
ms et cetera et cetera i could give you
a whole list yeah there's 85 of them oh
wow
and so
those are all inflammation related yes
so what inflammation means
is a real
it's really an autoimmune
disorder
inflammation is a byproduct
you know so the immune system is
misfiring
i mean it's
it's
sending a a white blood cell to
reduce a pathogen or a damaged cell and
in the process it's creating reactive
oxygen species
and there's no ground to reduce any
excess and so the excess radicals are
ripping electrons from healthy tissue
and so it's kind of like burning along
the log is on fire so the immune system
is sending you know firepower the
neutrophils or
you know cytokines or whatever uh to
reduce
and prevent damage but because it
doesn't have enough ground or enough
free electrons in the body enough redox
potential
or your ph is way off there throws a ph
of so if you don't have
enough
ground
it's a terrible word
but if you don't have enough
earth's free electrons or earths
um electrical
stability you know whatever negative
negative charge
anyhow then um
you're going to have inflammation so
it's
it's really
just get grounded let you know the body
of
absorbs these free electrons
uh they saturate the body to saturate
the tissue the red blood cells become
negatively charged and you know you
can't have inflammation i don't know if
i got off track there you have to
breathe well i'll tell you 13 months ago
i would wake up in the morning my ankles
especially if i had eaten something that
had triggered yes
some sort of inflammation a nightshade
vegetable for example
i would wake up in the morning with nine
out of 10 pain in my ankles especially i
felt like someone rolled my ankles i
used to play basketball when you roll
your ankle you have an acute
injury and there's inflammation there
but it felt like that most mornings for
me it doesn't feel like that ever now
with grounding
because i've removed
uh that that inflammation from my body
yeah well what you've done is you've
flooded with the body with free
electrons right from the earth and so
inflammation can't exist it can't
manifest
when your body's grounded
ryan what time is it you know what time
it is it's time for the lightning round
where we answer your text messages you
can text your questions your comments
your smart remarks to area code
937-202-4654 yes indeed those texts
actually go to both of our phones i'd
love to hear for folks who have tried
grounding what are some of your uh
subjective experiences that you've had
by the way if you uh text us you also
get on our monday morning minimal maxims
each monday we just send out a text
message no advertisers no junk no spam
we start your week off with a little bit
of simple living and so clint what we
try to do is we answer these questions
with short shareable less than 140
character response but not really we
ramble on a bit and then podcast john he
makes it look beautiful in the show
notes yeah so people can copy and share
our pithy answers on social media if
they'd like alabama it looks like sarah
has a question for us
if grounding is so beneficial why
doesn't mainstream medicine discuss it
more often now ryan when you first read
this question what did you think it said
i thought it said mainstream media and
then i get i sent josh my pithy answers
so he can like uh polish them up for me
and make them nice and beautiful for the
show and he sent it back and he was like
the the question doesn't say anything
about mainstream media and then i look
at the questions again and still saw
mainstream media i'm like yes it does
and then after like a fourth time
reading i was like oh it's mainstream
medicine but there are some similarities
between the two
expand on that clan because you said the
same thing okay
you know i have we have a lot of
doctors who use earthing products yes
and we have one that i referred to
because it was one of the first ones i
ran into cardiologists and there's like
three or four colleague cardiologists in
this in this group
and they kept ordering what we call a
recovery bag
and one day he ordered some and i said
you know i'm going to be driving by and
down in encinitas and i said i'd like to
drop them off for you and just meet you
and so i did and ran into the office and
said gave him to him and i said what do
you do with these things he says oh we
use them for our staff to stay off the
hypertension meds
and i said okay i didn't know too much
about
any of that at the time
and um then i said well why don't you
give these to your clients and to your
people he said oh he put his hand on my
shoulder he says son he said he pointed
at the door and he said every time
somebody walks through that door
they're worth x number of dollars for
testing now don't take this wrong this
is not attacking docs
this is this is a statement about our
times in our culture
but anyhow i said every time somebody
walks through that door he said first of
all i'm gonna run test
and and you know it's worth some large
amount of money then if i don't give
them script they're going to go
somewhere else
and they're my cable system i need those
people to come back every so many months
because that's how you know i make my
living so but anyhow the point of that
was not to knock doctors at all what it
is
is
like he said i'm married to a woman
who's married to a doctor that wants to
live like a woman who's married to a
doctor
okay that's part of it
meaning she spends money and i'm not
picking a woman here at all but um
beyond that i've got all the staff
i've got this building i've got lights i
have
um
you know
lots of overhead i'm still paying for
school you know
12 15 years of medical school oh my
goodness yeah and so this is a business
yes and it's a business taking care of
you these people aren't grounded they're
not going to get grounded in their words
they just want
palliative care meaning things to help
them cope with their health disorder
and and make it to
wherever
and there's a whole big crop coming
right behind them yeah so this is a
business
so you're nobody's going to stop
doing what they do because there's no
money in grounding
yeah you can't tell somebody to go home
and get well for free yeah
yeah yes yeah so that's one huge piece
of it right and then also josh was
talking about how like your doctor
wouldn't bring it up because he said he
didn't want to lose credibility that's
right yeah because any
and he's a functional medicine doctor he
does a lot of things that are sort of
outside the the conventional
mainstream narrative
but and we had tried a bunch of
unconventional things and then when i
stumbled across earth thing i realized
well wait a minute i went to talk to the
doctor about and he was like i'm just
ashamed i didn't tell you about this
sooner because
i i felt like you wouldn't have believed
me and the truth is i may not have
that's right because of the very first
question you were asked by tanya was how
do i explain this to people without
sounding hippie or woo-woo or or
spiritual or whatever it's like the way
that we explain it is it's reconnecting
to our ancestors because for hundreds of
thousands of years we and all other
living beings have been connected to
earth we recently disconnected ourselves
and along with that disconnection has
come dis-ease yeah fire
yeah we are on fire well here's a pithy
answer for you the truth is the truth
regardless of our beliefs so that's
really a roundabout way to address
sarah's question here yes maybe your
mainstream doctor doesn't know about the
truth that's part of it a lot of them
know they know what they know
yeah and they've specialized in that and
then also
it like a place like california for
example if you're a cancer doctor if
you're an oncologist
and you try to treat cancer outside of
basically chemotherapy or radiation
you are they remove your medical license
exactly and so you as a doctor you also
have to be careful that you're stepping
outside the bounds of the law that you
have you may not be able to help people
with
unconventional treatments in a legal way
because of the restrictions that are put
in place for your industry
and there's a reason for all of that
there there has to be a standard
protocol yes that everybody can work
with and hopefully they advance that and
you have the institutions the medical i
mean the
universities you have all of those
everybody's working in trying to improve
drugs and improve medical equipment and
protocols
but the problem is they're oblivious to
the effects
of grounding the
it's an environmental health disorder we
we've changed our bio terrain
yes you know it's but most people aren't
aware of that and doctors can't get into
you
into your your lifestyle
and what you eat and what you think
because all these things are
contributing to this inflammation
and um
so all they can do is help you cope with
what
you are presenting they have a computer
okay it's okay to give you this it's
okay to give you that and it's just the
way it is today and it's going to change
and it's going to be moms with autistic
children
and
mothers who that they're taking care of
that are
in with debilitating arthritis and
various other things it's going to be
these young moms who are going to change
the world yeah because when you start to
see pain relief for you or for the
people you love now you're eager because
it's added value to your life in some
way you're eager to share that with
other people that's why i i've bought
more copies of this book i think than
any other book this and the total money
makeover those two things
life-changing i i've uh just handed them
out like you know candy except it's much
healthier for you
ryan you got some of the pithy for us
yeah so the pithy answer that i that i
sent josh and uh uh yeah it said this
mainstream media prioritizes your
attention
over your well-being
so mainstream media prioritizes your
attention
over your well-being and the same thing
can be said with mainstream medicine
they want your time they want your money
um yes they'll give you some things to
to cure some ailments
but they are prioritizing uh things
before your well-being for sure and it
doesn't mean the doctors don't want to
help you but as clint elucidated here
there are other
factors involved yeah you know i i
wouldn't if it weren't for doctors i
wouldn't be here yeah of course yes and
so i i have a high respect for those who
are on point and absolutely doing the
right things you have the right
principles
but to a large degree america
capitalism
not just america the world
but capitalism and
you know money you know the wall street
and all of these things
it's all about making money yeah
and
pharmaceuticals and drug companies are
all about making money insurance
companies are public they have to create
more revenue to increase shareholder
value so they have to forever raise
prices and and so on and so on but it
goes on and on but we live in a society
where
money is at the bottom
it's the driving force behind everything
yeah so advertising media whatever media
they'll take a controversial history and
get on one side or the other just so
they can get eyeballs because they get
they make money by the amount of
eyeballs that are watching their program
yeah we get so much pressure to do
advertisements on our podcast and it
isn't a moral stance i just think that
advertisements are are gross yeah and so
i'm really thankful for our patreon
supporters because they keep the podcast
advertisement free even for the people
who don't pay to get you know we do two
episodes every week we do a minimal
episode a maximal episode the maxwell
episode is a deeper dive we could talk
about some things there like clint told
this whole story 40 minutes of him
living in montana and connecting with
native americans and we were really able
to dive deep there but it's thanks to
our patreon supporters not thanks to
yeah this episode is brought to you by
pfizer right exactly brought to you by
big mac
and here's here's the thing because
you mentioned the financial
responsibility but it's even
illegal to not put money first because
these companies have a fiduciary
responsibility
to
give money back to their shareholders
and so
how you can't have a fiduciary
responsibility and then also recommend
earthing no or yeah you know work or
you can't be a benevolent caring human
being you have to look everything about
money i have
my oldest daughter uh her husband went
through med school he's uh radiology
runs the radiology department for the
mayo clinic
and when he started out he wanted to be
a
a naturopath and he wanted to be
helping and and you know
you know like most doctors i believe
when they start yeah they want to be
humanitarian so yes but as time went on
it turned into money so all of a sudden
his life was not about
what he had in his dream when he went to
college it's about
you know making money for the
institution and there's nothing that's
the way it is you can't
say it's good or bad or whatever it is
the way it is we have built this system
we're locked into it but the only
way it can change is moms
there's no nobody else is going to
change it i can tell you my wife has and
she is
so healthy but even her
you know she would never she doesn't
have any chronic pain or anything like
that but as a 40 year old woman uh she
was 38 when we started grounding
she started experiencing better sleep
marginally improved at first and then
improved appreciably and then her
nervous system calmed down the chaos my
seven-year-old daughter her nervous
system calmed down she was less
sensitive to lights and loud noises
exactly and
all from
reconnecting with the earth and rounding
out the stress in your body oh man
grounding out the cortisol yeah well
real quick for right here right now
here's one thing that's going on in the
life of the minimalist i know we
mentioned patreon earlier but this week
we're putting up the fifth and final
studio tour although i don't think it's
gonna be the final because we're getting
ready to make a whole change in the
studio yeah so it'll be the fifth and
final part of season one of the studio
tour
so we got five different studio tours up
there right now patreon.com the
minimalist that's for the true fan tier
and the vips
alabama what else you got for us here
are some voicemail comments and insights
from our listeners
hey josh and ryan uh brad in new york
here i have suggestions to people trying
to get rid of items it doesn't
necessarily have to be a physical object
deleting superfluous apps from your
phone can count too digital clutter is
still clutter
hey guys my name is justin and i'm
calling from columbus ohio hopefully you
guys are aware in your home home state
of ohio that the opioid prescription
crisis
is at an all-time high
when it comes to the abuse and misuse of
prescription medication and one of the
things that's been developed through the
ohio state university is a program
called generation rx and one of the key
takeaways
is educating the public about
the proper use of prescription
medication as well as the proper
disposal as i've been listening to your
guys's podcast and learning about some
of the principles that you guys are
teaching on it can be applied to as a
potential solution
for this crisis and
by applying the
simplifying and minimalizing your drug
cabinet or your medicine cabinet
and going through and properly disposing
of
prescription medications that aren't
being used because one out of four
people that misuse or abuse a
prescription drug got them from a family
member or friend a lot of times that's
just
prescription drugs that are hanging out
in the medicine cabinet you know that
can be uh minimized when they're no
longer needed
all right y'all before we wrap up and
get to our added value segment
i want to thank clint ober for being
here today and we just want to
acknowledge you for writing this book
yeah earthing the most important health
discovery ever if folks want to check it
out we'll put a link to the book in the
show notes we'll also put a link to your
film which is available to watch for
free on youtube and commercial free and
also they can check out earthing.com in
fact that's our added value this week
all of the products that you sell
although you were stumbled into this
people were begging you and in fact i
would be the first person to beg you for
this because the grounding mat that i
have on my bed totally changed my life
because it means every night i'm
grounding for eight hours the grounding
mats we're standing on right now we
didn't get them for free ryan and i paid
for these grounding mats and um
all of your other products that you
offer at earthing.com is because there
was a strong demand right i will say
this though you don't need any product
to go earthing amen you can do it for
free and you have the heart of a servant
you're trying to help people educate
people and that's what really all of
this is about and i'm so grateful you
decided to join us today man yeah thanks
clint
thanks for giving me the opportunity to
share with your people
if you uh want to connect with all the
science as well clint runs the earthing
institute you can find it at earthing
institute dot net we'll put a link to
all of that in the show notes by the way
we got a bunch more surprise questions
this week like in what ways are man-made
emfs harming us
can we ground while wearing socks can we
ground on concrete
how does grounding relate to pemf
therapy infrared saunas and other
alternative healing practices plus a
million more questions for clint ober
and the minimalists and if you want to
hear all that check out the minimalist
private podcast this week visit
patreon.com
the minimalist to subscribe and get your
personal link so that our weekly private
podcast plays in your favorite podcast
app you also gain immediate access to
hundreds of hours of private archives
recordings of live events exclusive home
tours and our private community of
thousands of open-minded minimizers like
you you can follow the minimalists on
tick tock instagram facebook and twitter
at the minimalists if you want our
podcast show notes or in your inbox sign
up for our email list over at
theminimalists.com on behalf of ryan
nicodemus podcast sean alabama jordan no
more social jess danny unknown
post-production peter emma the immigrant
and the rest of our team i'm joshua
fields milburn if you leave here today
with just one message
let it be this
love people
and use things
because the opposite never works
thanks for listening y'all we'll see you
next time
every little thing
you think that you need
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing
that's just feeding your greed oh i bet
that you'll be fine without it
everyone